I'm gonna go live and push stream, I'm already streaming I think.
Start streaming.
Alright Porter, let's check Facebook and see if we're live here.
I think we are dude, let me see.
Sure.
Yeah it says you're live, yeah we're live.
Okay dope.
Alright.
Let me go, I don't know why, oh there it is, boom.
Okay dude, let's wait a second, we'll see if anyone comes up.
Can you tag people on the stream like you can in a group or not?
I don't know, let me see.
Hey dude, let me try it, see hold on.
I do add, yeah I think you can tag people, you can probably tag everybody.
I'm trying to do tag everyone, trying to drop a comment on the stream and see if it will
let me, oh there we go Porter's watching, that's, maybe it's app followers you do, yeah
it's app followers, come check this out.
Alright dope.
Okay so, let's just jump into this dude, we gotta, I know you're doing stuff, you're,
I mean tell everyone what you're doing by the way.
I'll give you a nice little view, I'm weighing out some trucks right now so I am, oh geez
I can't even.
What does that mean for everyone, for 99% of people I have no idea what that means.
So I'm weighing these trucks into this scale house, this is my guy, I gotta hop out, weigh
him in and then I gotta weigh him out.
This guy, you know what's funny dude, this guy drove clear to Mesquite and he forgot
to get a weigh ticket and then he had to drive back.
Okay you let that guy wait five minutes then, let's do a quick intro then I'll take care.
We got Mr. Moin Gollum, what's up bro, Laura Shepard, you got a few people on, guys in
this video, this little live that me and Porter are gonna do, Porter can you just be on for
like five minutes?
Yeah here we go.
Okay, in this video what I wanna do is I actually just wanna go over, like just, first of all
I wanna explain to you how much money you can actually make from renting a simple website.
And if you don't know what I'm talking about with renting a simple website, I'm gonna
explain that here in a second.
And I'm not just gonna tell you, I'm gonna show you my Stripe account, I'm gonna show
you some screenshots of some of my clients and like I'm actually gonna show you a list
of like part of my clients.
The reason being is because a lot of people that have seen these videos that Porter and
I have done in the past, I think you see these videos and it's like, yeah it sounds
like it's awesome but it kind of feels too good to be true.
Would you say that that's, did you feel like that when you found out like I was doing this
or what was your thoughts?
Because I know that if I was from the outside looking in and somebody's like, yeah you can
travel the world and do all this stuff and pay your bills renting out simple websites,
I would probably be like, eh, I'm not sure I believe that.
It seems like it's just like you want to believe that but at the same time you're like, can
I do that?
Like it doesn't seem like you're qualified enough to be able to make that kind of money.
But did you think that it was actually real or did you think it was just like me making
some fake screenshots on Stripe because I think that people actually do think that is
the reality.
I actually want to show you guys some screenshots of some clients that I have and that I've
been working with for years.
So anyway, I guess you probably didn't have that thought because you would assume I wouldn't
lie to you.
Yeah.
I mean, I had a lot more.
I had a lot more faith.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well, anyway, so let's just do this really quick, dude.
I want to just tell my story quickly, just catch people up, just literally 15 seconds.
You the same.
We'll tell people the model and then I'll let you hop off.
So I do see Jerry, let's see, we've got Laura Shepard on there, Richard Martez, what's up?
Jerry Ward.
Good to see you, bro.
We need to catch up by the way.
We need to catch up when I was out of the country.
Jimmy Carlson.
Okay.
So in a nutshell, guys, I used to do door to door sales.
That was like the only job, the only real job I had.
It wasn't even on payroll.
It was knocking door to door.
I realized that if I wanted to make real money, and again, that real money is defined by different
people, but money where I would say seven figures plus, I needed to do something where
I actually owned the thing.
I couldn't be a salesperson.
I couldn't be an employee.
And so I'm like, I knew I needed to start a business.
Didn't know what to do.
I was asking everybody.
I was taking people to lunch.
All that.
Just being that annoying guy.
Like, hey, what should I do?
What should I do?
I don't know.
And I was making decent money doing door to door sales.
So I came across this business model.
Somebody introduced me to this specific podcast and said, hey, you should check this out.
Looked it up and it was talking about this idea where what you do is you pick a city,
you pick a niche.
So for example, Para One Tree Service, you build a simple website and then you rank that
website on Google.
And from once it ranks, you're going to start getting phone calls.
You take those phone calls and you sell the phone calls.
So you're essentially a middleman.
You are you're like a lead broker, right?
So this is the model.
It made perfect sense to me because they explained like once you do this, it's it's passive.
You have these websites that are out on the Internet collecting phone calls and you're
selling the leads and you're not even involved.
It's passive business model.
So I was completely hooked.
Long story short, I got into this in 2016, been doing this nine years, made all the mistakes
in the book.
I've I've almost I almost quit doing it twice.
Got distracted, tried to start a software company that didn't work.
And then finally in 2020, I was like, you know what, Nick, you got to figure this out.
Like you got to start actually making some some good money from this.
This is the right model.
You just got to put your head down.
And we made some adjustments and we made some tweaks.
We figured out a few things that I didn't know how to do.
And everything changed.
And since 2020, been making seven figures, one hundred thousand plus per month since
2020. OK, Porter, tell everyone really quick how you how you got into it.
And then we'll get into just showing some examples and letting people see that this
is actually real. Perfect.
So two years ago, when I got back from Colorado, I reached out to Nick.
I just got married.
And it was just kind of that point in my life where I was like, dude, I got to start
making some more money, like rent's expensive, food's expensive.
I mean, just everything in general.
I just didn't realize what it took to, you know, live out on your own.
And so that's kind of when I actually drew an interest in what you did.
I was like, dude, what are you doing?
I remember we had a conversation and you told it to me.
And I was like, it almost like it didn't make sense because I was like, what?
Like, that's all you did. And it kind of just was like this joke.
I was like, are you serious? This is crazy.
And then anyways, started doing it myself.
And for a little bit, it was hard.
It was just like my confidence, getting my confidence there of like, can I actually
do this? I have zero sales experience.
I have zero tech skills.
Like, why should I be able to sell this?
And you had been through summer sales, doing all these things.
So like I knew I could do it and I knew that you were like capable of like,
obviously this was real.
But, you know, until I fully bought into it, that was kind of when I saw the results
and it just changed my life.
And just to just give an idea.
So Porter, what's your what are you making per month doing this right now?
Ten six right now, ten thousand six hundred.
Ten thousand six hundred bucks.
OK, so that's what Porter makes per month.
By the way, this is not Porter's full time thing.
As you can see, Porter is taking five minutes to jump on this call, but he's full
time taking over the family farm, doing that.
He likes to work with his hands.
This is just a side thing for him.
He does it during the winters and then he kind of maintains it during the summers
when he's working on the family farm.
So you don't have to do this full time.
I personally started doing this while I was doing door to door sales.
I've been doing this full time, though, for, you know, five, six, seven years.
But you don't have to do this full time.
OK, so what I'm going to do is this.
Porter's making ten thousand six hundred bucks.
Again, I wanted him to be out here to tell you that just because it sounds like
when you think about the idea of building a simple website, it sound
and then renting it out, it sounds like you're full of crap.
That's that's the reality.
And I understand that.
So I'm going to be showing you a couple of examples on this call.
I'm going to show you some screenshots.
I know Porter's got to go here in a second.
But just so you guys understand how this works is once you rank one of these websites.
So let me just show one site, Porter, that you can bounce.
OK, no, you're good.
OK, let me show you guys this real quick.
I'm going to share my screen.
Hang on one second.
I'm going to go to a good old Google dot com, and then I'm going to share my screen.
I'm going to show everyone that has no idea what we're talking about, what this is.
OK, you can see my screen.
Yep, I can see it.
So here's how simple the model is.
Somebody goes to Google, they're in St.
George, Utah. They're looking for concrete, right?
They want a new patio.
They want a basketball court.
They want to extend their pool deck, whatever.
They want to put in a sidewalk.
They're going to go and they're probably going to go and type in concrete St.
George. Pretty simple.
St. George, concrete, concrete, St.
George, concrete company.
And what's going to happen is when you type this in, you're going to see these.
These at the top are sponsored ads.
OK, but if you go down here just a little bit, you're going to see these three
listings here and then you're going to see underneath, you're going to have some
more listings. OK, so if you see, I'm going to show you guys where I'm actually
ranking and how much money I'm making from this, and it's going to surprise you.
So if you can see this, this isn't my website.
This isn't my website. This is actually my website.
I'm ranked number three.
I'm not even ranked number one.
I'm also not ranked in the top three here.
If you change this, sometimes it will change it.
If you type in concrete St.
George or St.
George, concrete, sometimes if you switch it around.
So now I'm number two.
So it kind of depends.
But I want you to understand, I'm not the first listing.
OK, if you click on this site, somebody's in St.
George are looking for concrete.
They're going to come to this little website.
Nothing pretty, nothing fancy.
And if they call this phone number right here, I get paid.
OK, this is tracked.
It goes directly to the business owner.
The phone rings. I get paid.
If they fill this thing out right here.
Hey, I want to get an estimate, blah, blah, blah.
I get paid.
And that's it. That's it.
That's the whole model.
Build a site, rank it on Google for things that people search.
When people call the phone number, you get paid.
Is there anything else I could explain
that makes that even more simple?
No, it's literally digital real estate.
If you had an actual tenant in a rental house,
that's the easiest way for me to explain it is like it's
someone's renting the site from you every single month.
So before Porter goes, let me show you guys.
I just pulled this up on my this is my Stripe account.
Literally pulled this up today.
You can see right here, February.
What is the date today?
Nineteenth.
Yeah, this is literally I do that.
I screenshot this right before I jumped on.
OK, so this one website that I just really showed you guys,
you can see right here, I have made from this one singular
client, I have made sixty four thousand one hundred and
twenty five dollars.
OK, I signed the client in November of twenty twenty one.
Looks like we might have either had a pause
or they missed a few payments right here.
You could see my graph over here, my monthly revenue with them.
They pay me one thousand six hundred and thirty dollars
and fifty eight cents.
It looks like I had to give one refund, which probably was we
accidentally charged them twice.
And you could see every single week I get paid three hundred
and seventy five bucks.
Boom, boom, boom.
OK, let me see if I can go back to the site.
Here's the site.
So this little guy right here, St.
George Concrete CEO dot com, in all of its glory, is ripping
down one thousand six hundred and thirty dollars and fifty
eight cents per month.
Three hundred seventy five dollars a week.
I don't know about you, but that could almost cover a house
payment, depending on which part of the country.
And maybe not anymore.
Maybe that's like half a house payment now.
But you get two sites, you get your house paid for your
mortgage paid for.
So this is what we do.
So this is one of my sites I have.
So I'll show one more screenshot, then I'll show a
couple more examples.
But Porter, let me just show you this, dude, or I guess
everybody in here.
Here's a well, actually, I'll let you go, dude.
Do you have anything you want to add?
I know you got to go and do your real job, but it's good to
see that you can like Porter does this.
He has leads coming in.
He's trying to get his clothes and deals working with new
business owners while he's working on the farm.
And he's been able to scale this to ten thousand six
hundred dollars per month in addition to what he's doing on
the farm, which I think is amazing.
Anything you want to add?
No pressure.
But if you do.
No, I would just say anyone can do this.
I used to think that I had to be sitting at a desk and I had
all this free time to be able to make this work.
But seriously, you can do this anywhere.
Like you don't need to be sitting at a desk.
Like I feel like I almost get more done.
Like I'm just doing my everyday life and I'm continually
sitting over leads, hooking business owners, getting on the
phone and stuff like that.
So anyone could do this and you don't need sales experience.
That's like the biggest thing.
I think a lot of people are like, I'm afraid to get on the
phone. I've never done summer sales.
Like I'm fresh out of high school, whatever it is.
And it's like, dude, you don't just be yourself.
There are certain people that you're going to be able to
connect with that maybe I'm not going to be able to connect
with. So anyways.
Yeah. And just so everybody knows, when I first started
doing this, I had zero experience with the computer.
I didn't know how to build a website.
I didn't know what SEO meant, which means search engine
optimization. I didn't know what a domain was.
I knew how to work on the farm and knock doors.
That's it. That's all I knew how to do.
I didn't know how to do sales.
Well, actually, that's not true.
I had done door-to-door sales.
When I started doing door-to-door sales, I didn't know
how to do sales.
I knew how to do sales.
I did not know how to do anything technical.
Porter didn't know how to do anything technical.
And he also didn't have any sales experience.
So yeah, I double whammy.
But the cool part is we've actually seen some of our
friends, some of the kids that we went to high school with,
like even in the last week, we've seen not a lot,
but a handful of people that have kind of been watching for
years. And they're finally like, dude,
I should have done this two years ago instead of being out
there in the cold and under the sun,
actually doing manual labor,
which there's a hundred percent nothing wrong with that
actually feels really good to do manual labor.
But this allows you to do, to travel, to be wherever,
to be farming.
I like to travel.
I'm in Africa a lot and you can do this from anywhere.
So Porter, I'm going to show a couple more examples,
but you can hop off and go take care of the truck that's
waiting on you, bro.
Okay. Appreciate it.
See ya.
So guys, I'm just going to show you a couple more examples of
some sites that I've done this with.
And then I'm going to hop off.
That's it.
So here's another example.
If you type in, I'll give you one more St. George one.
If you type in St. George epoxy.
So, you know, when you go into your garage and you have like
an epoxy floor where, I mean,
I didn't even really know what this was growing up,
but then you moved to St. George.
I moved to St. George.
A lot of people had it.
So I'll show you the images here.
So this is like an epoxy garage floor right here.
It makes the garage super nice, super clean,
super easy to clean up.
So if you type in St. George epoxy,
you're going to see me right here at the very top.
Again, these are sponsored ads.
So this means they're paying for this.
So I'm actually the number one person here.
This is my website, stgeorgeopoxy.com.
This is my phone number.
If you call this phone number, I get paid.
Okay. And when I say I get paid,
what I mean by that is my business owners I work with,
they pay me a certain amount every single month
for all the phone calls.
You can do different structures where you can have it set up
where every time the phone rings,
they pay you a certain amount.
I don't like to do it that way
because it's a lot of tracking
and there's a lot of back and forth.
I like to just do a flat fee, make it easy.
I'm the business owner, make it easy on me.
But just for the sake of teaching you guys
and showing you guys what the heck it is I do,
if this phone rings, that's how I get paid.
Okay. So let me show you how much money I've made
from this website right here.
Let me see if I can pull up my screenshot.
Let's see here.
Hang tight.
I think it might be this one.
There it is.
Okay.
Nope. That's another one I'm going to show you.
Let me go to this one.
Okay. So this one right here,
once again, guys, see if you can see this.
I don't know if you can see me.
I can't see myself, hold on.
I'm not sharing my screen anymore.
Sorry, guys.
I didn't even show you that last one.
This is the website I was showing you guys, sorry.
If you type in St. George Epoxy on Google,
you're going to go, you're going to see my website
here at the top, stgeorgeepoxy.com.
You can see it's super simple.
That's it.
If you call this phone number right here, I get paid.
That's what I was trying to say.
So I thought I was sharing my screen
when I was showing you this.
That's another one of my websites.
Here's how much I've made from that website.
So you can see right here, St. George Epoxy leads.
Let's see.
You can see right here.
It doesn't really show the date,
but I just screenshot this right before I came on.
You can see right here, it shows all the way till February.
I don't see anywhere that it shows the actual date.
This one's a little bit lower.
I make $652.23.
Why? Because the jobs aren't worth as much money.
And so I don't get paid as much.
So it's not my favorite niche.
I'd rather go into concrete, but I do have this one.
This guy has been paying me since June of 2020,
and I've made $36,350.
I get paid 150 bucks a week.
Again, 150 bucks isn't gonna make you rich,
but you do that 100 times,
and you're gonna have some nice money coming in.
One thing that's cool about this deal that I did,
I actually, including on top of the money that they paid me,
we actually worked out a deal where this guy did my garage,
and I actually got my garage completely blacked out,
and it looks really, really cool.
So he did that at cost.
I paid for the material.
He actually did the labor.
Okay, let me show you one more website,
and then I'll hop off here.
There's one more deal.
This is another one I did a couple years ago.
Let's see.
Type in Bentonville Concrete.
You're gonna see me here at the top.
You're also gonna see me here.
You're gonna see me that I'm ranked a couple times
on page one, depending on the search term,
but I'm right here at the top.
You click on this.
Another one of my little dinky websites.
Guys, these are not special.
I don't know how to code.
I don't know how to use WordPress.
This is literally built on weebly.com.
This website right here, as soon as you call this,
it goes to my business owner.
It tracks it for me,
and then I send him an invoice every month
and run his credit card.
That's it, okay?
This one, this specific website,
I have made, let me show you here.
Right here.
I have made $52,725.
Now, you see this pass due.
This just means we ran this person's card today,
and it didn't go through.
Maybe he's over the limit or changed cards or whatever,
but what will happen is in two, three days,
we'll hit the card again and it'll run.
So you can see right here, I get paid $978.34
every single month.
It's 225 bucks a week.
I've been working with him since June of 2020.
Ironically, I've actually been working with him longer.
I think I was even working with him the year before,
or six months before that,
but we were running it under a different Stripe account.
But over that course of time,
I've made $52,725.
You can see right here, we started in this account
on June 4th.
$52,725 from this, okay?
This is not fancy.
This is not hard to build.
This website took me probably a week to build,
weeks worth of hours,
so probably 40 to 50 hours worth of time I put into this,
and it's paid me $52,000.
Now, granted, I had to go get the client,
I had to put the deal together.
I do keep the relationship with the client,
but this is, I mean, consider if you knew
you could go spend 50 hours and build something
that was gonna make you $52,000 over the next four years,
wouldn't you do that 100 times?
That's what I've been doing
for the past three, four, five years,
and I've just been stacking these sites,
stacking these sites.
150 bucks a week here, 350 here, 500 there, 100 here,
and these things just continually add up
until you start making quite a bit of money, okay?
So last thing I wanna show you guys really quick,
just for fun, I'll show you a little sample list
of some of my clients here.
I'm not gonna show you their names, obviously,
but I took this screenshot and just blurred out the names.
Just to show you, this is my Stripe account,
did this today, right here, date as of February 18th,
so I guess that's as of yesterday, maybe.
But anyway, you can see right here,
here's my list of clients I'm obviously not gonna show you,
but I've got somebody that's paid me over 132,000.
This one's paid me 64, 57, 54, 52, 47, 46, 36, 35,
33, 32, 29, 29.
This is not all my clients, this is one page of my clients.
You can see right here, these things stack up,
24, 26, 27, 28, all the way up to 132.
And yes, sometimes we have clients
that you start working with,
and then after three to six months, it doesn't work out.
And you go and you part ways and then you take your website.
But here's the beautiful thing, guys,
is when does it work out with the client, right?
So let's say that this specific client
that I'm dealing with here,
let's say this guy calls me and he's like,
hey, I don't wanna buy these leads anymore,
I'm doing something else, I don't have any money,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Okay, it's not a big deal because I'm just gonna take
this website, I'm gonna go to my software,
which is, we use this thing called rankandrentengine.com,
and I'm gonna change the phone number
so that when people call this phone number,
it goes to my new business owner.
I'll change it so he's paying me instead of the old guy.
No damage done, it's just like owning properties, right?
If you own a house, you put a tenant in it,
they pay you every month.
If you have to evict that tenant, guess what?
You put somebody else in, they pay you.
That's it, that's the whole game.
Think about this like building houses all over the internet,
but instead of houses, they're websites.
You're building these miniature passive income streams
all over the internet.
The way that I look at it is I have, I don't know,
35 to 50 of these websites, I don't know the exact number
that are rented out versus how many we have,
but every single day, while we're talking right now,
these websites are out there collecting phone calls.
When I'm sleeping, when I'm golfing,
when I'm traveling to Africa,
when I'm doing my team meeting,
which I'm about to do here in one minute,
I'm making money from these websites.
It's like, I always think about it like this show,
Despicable Me, and Gru has the minions, right?
And they're literally just working,
and they're just doing stuff for them.
I don't think, if I remember the show right,
they have to eat.
The one thing with these minions is they do have
like personalities and feelings.
These don't have feelings, these don't have personalities,
these don't need time off, these don't need vacations,
these don't need compliments, and you tell them
that they're doing a good job, they just go to work for you.
You build them, you rank them, you set them free,
and they go and they collect dollars for you
all over the internet while you do what you love to do.
So, anyway, for anyone that might have been curious,
maybe you weren't curious at all,
maybe you just think it's annoying that I keep posting this,
I'm sorry, you can unfollow me.
I use these social medias for business,
social media channels for business,
but for those of you that are curious, interested,
whatever, this is how it works.
You build these sites, you rank them,
you rent them out to local business owners,
you get paid, you do it again, you do it again,
you do it again.
You spend your life doing what you love to do
instead of working for somebody else, okay?
That's the whole game.
So, that said, the only thing I'll do really quick,
I have a couple of, if you guys are interested,
I have a free training,
because people are like, how do you learn more,
rentsimplesites.com.
Give me one second.
Rentsimplesites.com, that's a free training.
And then we also have a community,
which is, if you go to rankandretire.com.
Again, no pressure, these are just some resources.
And then I'm actually gonna do this.
I talked to Porter, I have a deal with him,
anybody that he does this with,
I actually make sure he's taken care of,
but I'm gonna drop Porter's number.
If you guys have any questions,
you can literally text Porter, this is his own cell phone,
you can text Porter, and he will text you back,
or hop on a call with you,
and just kinda walk you through it.
So, anyway, if you guys are curious, there you go.
If not, no big deal, thanks for being on the live.
I'm gonna jump onto a team meeting.
Happy February, stay warm,
see you guys on the next one, I'm out.